the word nonprofit scares me a little
bit but it freaks the hell out of my
parents have you ever wanted to do
something that you knew there was little
to no money in and can you offer myself
any advice yes no I've never wanted to
do that but but you can kill em keep the
bike for a second but it's really
interesting timing that you ask this I'm
on the board of a non-profit called
pencils of promise and pop was started
by an unbelievable young man named Adam
drawed Adam Braun's brother happens to
be Scooter Braun the guy who discovered
Justin Bieber here are two brothers and
they went in very very different
directions now imagine your bro who's a
year younger or older excuse me in this
scenario not only didn't go nonprofit
but when [ __ ] found the beeps right
and made tens of billions of dollars
he's run popped for about a decade and
now he just got married a couple years
ago and not making any money has gotten
to a place in his life where he's
already done more good for the world
than 99% of people and he's now going
he's just left that he's now our
Chairman heiress but he's no longer
involved and he's going and trying to
build what he now needs financially I'll
tell you this we've never lived through
generation where young people are
willing to go that path the cliche path
is the way I always thought about the
way I was gonna give back right build a
huge Empire buy the Jets and then start
giving back right
I got affected 5 to 7 years ago by Scott
Harrison who's the founder of charity
water also very progressive nonprofit
and he said Gary you can give along the
way you don't have to build it all up
and give it away and I've done that and
it's been very rewarding to me but as a
lot of you know I don't talk a lot about
my nonprofit work I think you know
there's a lot of things that keep
private
I keep all my good [ __ ] private you know
I just do it's just how I roll but I
don't think anybody can tell you how to
live your life you just need to make
sure that you mean it so I have a lot of
23 24 year olds 22 year olds right now
that don't know exactly what they want
to do and they painted a narrative that
they want to be a non-profit because
they like the brand Association of
making themselves feel like they're
better human beings than the other
people I'm not joking
you need to make sure is that what
you're doing or do you actually want to
do it if you actually want to do it you
go ahead first but if there's a part of
you that likes the narrative that it
paints on you as a human being and
you're concerned about the other parts
like money and other things you don't
have to you have to beat yourself up
about that